you know saying not like they can they
can get like the these high earning men
it's just it's the same thing it's just
telling them what they want to hear
because they want that in a Munch or the
advice is oh yeah um you write in one in
that you deserve that B all that you
know when at the end of the day
they need to hear is
you need a reality check and you need to
shot your adults just like you ain't
going anywhere do you think that's all
women like what we saw in the video or
do you think it's a certain type of
ethnicity or demographic of women this
is a question for everybody I mean I
could I could keep it 100 and say that's
more of a problem in the black community
I think in my opinion I can't speak to
that I'm not gonna hide his way